der schriftsteller tc boyle ist einer
der meistgelesenen chronisten amerikas
hat eine schwäche für außenseiter und
beobachtet den mainstream mit innigem
grimm aus alltäglichkeiten baut er große
dramen die eher witzig nicht selten
sogar aber witzig durch spielt so auch
in seinem letzten roman wenn das
schlachten vorbei ist ein film über
unseren selbstzerstörerischen umgang mit
der natur
juri steiner spricht mit dem kultauto
über den ganz normalen wahnsinn unserer
zeit die anstehende us präsidentenwahl
und tc boyles selbst eingestandenen
schreibt sucht diese welt sie sind
schreibt wichtig sie sind professor sie
sind ein literarischer rockstar und für
manche sogar ein guru sie haben sich
seit den 70er jahren sehr intensiv mit
der amerikanischen gesellschaft
auseinandergesetzt mit den hippies mit
dem berühmten exzentrikern der jüngeren
amerikanischen geschichte wie harvey
kellogg den gesundheits guru mit dem
sexualforscher kind sie dann mit dem
sexualleben des architekten frank lloyd
wright sehen sie sich selber in dieser
ahnengalerie der berühmten
amerikanischen exzentriker ich muss
etwas gestehen ich bin selbst ein
amerikanischer exzentriker wie sie wohl
vermutet schön an dem was ich tue ist
das aus allem was mich interessiert ein
roman entsteht
ich bin kein tiefgründiger denker ich
bin weder ein guru noch ein philosoph
aus einem berg ich bin einfach durch und
durch künstler und aus allem was ich
ergründen möchte mache ich eine
geschichte
ich weiß nicht warum das zuerst aber ich
bin sehr glücklich darüber haben wir
aber nicht raten historische figuren
beschrieben oder umgebaut den literatur
sie haben auch in ihren unzähligen
büchern und und novellen hunderte wenn
nicht tausende von menschen figur und
geschaffen diesen figuren namen gegeben
und sich selbst hatten sie ja auch einen
namen gegeben ich glaube ich auf zweiter
vorname pakistan haben sie sich selbst
gegeben haben sie sich damit auch zu
einer kunstfigur gemacht
im jugendlichen alter von 17 jahren
realisierte ich dass ich irgendwie
besonders war
wir wollen alle etwas besonderes sein
aber mein name ist thomas john boy juni
das ist ähnlich wie hans schmid der
gewöhnlichste name der welt ich hatte
keine ahnung dass ich einmal
schriftsteller würde ich wusste damals
nicht einmal das schreiben eine berufung
sein könnte aber ich fand ich bräuchte
einen charakteristischen nahmen die nur
ich hatte also kam ich aber meine
verleger haben dann meinen vornamen auf
tiefsee reduziert das ist für alle auf
der welt einfach meine engsten freunde
haben meinen namen noch mehr verkürzt
nämlich auf meine frau nennt mich und
meine kinder nennen mich
erstaunlicherweise denn seltsamerweise
wusste ich nicht dass sich künstler
werden würde studierte damals musik
wollte musiker werden
ich muss wohl gedacht haben etwas würde
ich eines tages zu stande einen also
brauchte ich einen namen der dem
entsprach man nehme einen namen die nur
ich hatte ich unterhalte gerne menschen
auf der ganzen welt
ich vermittle gerne meine liebe für die
literatur
unabhängig davon wie tief es ist sie uns
bewegt oder zum lachen bringt denn jede
kunst ist grundsätzlich unterhaltung und
kommunikation auf meiner lesereise durch
österreich deutschland und die schweiz
habe ich mich mit vielen schülern
getroffen
die meine bücher im unterricht lesen oft
auf englisch gestern habe ich eine
klasse getroffen und gefragt hast ihr
mich jetzt da ich inzwischen zum kanon
gehöre sind meine bücher pflichtlektüre
es ist arbeit sie müssen darüber
schreiben ich finde das nicht richtig
man sollte einen roman lesen weil es ein
subversives vergnügen ist diese
subversive freude und die freude mit dem
spiel des entertainment ist in ihrem
neuesten buch wenn das schlachten vorbei
ist ja ziemlich radikal gegen den strich
gekämmt also nur schon der titel in das
schlachten verweist lässt nichts gutes
ahnen in diesem buch ist auch nicht viel
gutes für die zukunft oder für die
hoffnung drin viel entertainment
trotzdem es geht um unsere welt das geht
um uns wie wir sieben milliarden
menschen diese welt zerstören wir sind
einfach zu viel es gibt gute menschen
darin die die welt retten möchten und es
trotzdem nicht schaffen so gut sie auch
sind sie haben diesem buch ein
bibelzitat vorangestellt und gott
segnete sie und sprach zu ihnen zu den
menschen seid fruchtbar und mehret euch
und fülle die erde und mache sie euch
untertan und hersteller über die fische
im meer und über die vögel unter dem
himmel und über das vieh und über alles
getier das auf erden kriecht das erste
buch moses 128 ist das nun zynisch oder
verzweifelt zu verstehen ich würde noch
so gern allen auf der welt besseres über
die umweltbericht aber das kann ich
nicht ich versuche einfach diese dinge
selbst zu verstehen natürlich berechtigt
uns dieses zitat aus der genesis laut
der westlichen mittel
die über die anderen tiere zu herrschen
aber eigentlich haben wir kein recht die
anderen tiere wegen eine laune der
evolution zu dominieren
ich vergleiche uns gerne mit dem grizzly
bären oder dem hier heimischen
braunbären
sie sind nah miteinander verwandt obwohl
der grizzly viel mehr gefürchtet ist
er hat sich nicht so sehr an die
menschen gewöhnt wie ein braunbär der
amerikanische grizzly bear gilt als
größtes und gefürchtetes tier
er rennt schneller als ein pferd hat
einen feinen geruchssinn als 100 gründe
und cannes ausgezeichnet sehen
er hat sich zum könig seines lebensraums
entwickelt doch zur gleichen zeit
stiegen in afrika ein paar party von den
bäumen herunter wurden zwei weiner und
entwickelten ein großes gehirn dank
dessen sie zum beispiel das gewehr
erfanden und grizzlybären töten zu
können
es ist nur eine laune der evolution das
wir sind was wir sind
das gab wie ich bereits gesagt habe ich
stellte dem roman dieses zitat voran
damit wir uns gedanken darüber machen
können
es ist eine frage der moral wie wir die
anderen kreaturen der erde behandeln
aber natürlich auch ein zitat von darwin
am anfang dieses buches stellen können
und quasi dann diese frage nach der
moral auch auf die seite finden sich ich
habe da wenn auch schon oft in diesem
zusammenhang zitiert mir gefällt das
zitat für dieses buch denn die westliche
zivilisation gründet auf dem christentum
und wie der islam und die anderen großen
religionen gibt das christentum unserer
menschlichen existenz einen sinn
es ist einfach wenn sie daran glauben
wissen sie warum wir existieren
das hinterfrage ich hätte ich ein zitat
von darwin oder beides vorangestellt
hätte es an wert eingebüßt in der
diskussion über die ethik in der
die gesellschaft erwarte dass die ersten
zu sein die ethik frage ist er nicht nur
die des kritikers dies jetzt erwähnt
haben der einfach stärker schneller ist
und halb frisst was er kriegen kann was
nicht zu schnell auf den bäumen ist
in ihrem buch geht es ja um
umweltschützer um gute menschen die
etwas gutes tun möchten die gewisse
prozesse wieder rückgängig machen
möchten also es geht konkret darum dass
vor der küste von kalifornien inseln
sind die besiedelt wurden mit den
menschen kamen raten kann man schweine
es gibt die geologin arbeit die das
wieder rückgängig machen möchte und als
angestellte des national park service es
diese tiere abschießen lässt oder
vergiften lassen
und es gibt den radikalinskis auf den
anderen seite dave la shoah der quasi
gegen alba kämpft also gegen dieses
rückwärts machen das schlachten im guten
sinne
und hier haben wir wieder ein eingreifen
also ein gut gemeintes eingreifen ist
das ein jahr von perversion
ich interpretiere man normal nicht das
ist verboten
wenn der autor sagt was sein buch
bedeutet zerstörte es für jeden leser
schön an der kunst ist dass man den
leser einlädt sich zu engagieren
das eingreifen der aktivisten pervers
ist überlasse ich ihrem urteil aber da
tritt die wissenschaft auf den plan
wir sprachen über das bibelzitat doch
eigentlich geht es im roman um die
prinzipien der insel biogeographie ja es
gibt eine ironie in der
umweltschutzbewegung denn das sind
menschen welche die welt retten wollen
die welt braucht aber keiner
gerettet werden müssen die
lebensgrundlagen welche die entwicklung
unseres pcs ermöglicht haben
wir erleben die globale erwärmung um das
aussterben von tierarten laut
wissenschaftlern ist es das sechste
große massenaussterben der erdgeschichte
hier zerstören unsere lebensgrundlagen
die geschichte die ich erzähle beruht
auf eine begebenheit die sie in den
letzten zehn jahren auf dem
kalifornischen kanalinseln zugetragen
hat es geht um die wiederherstellung des
ökosystems
es ist eine art moral stück in dem beide
seiten vertreten sind
jeder leser jede leserin kann
entscheiden welche seite vertretbar ist
und überhaupt eine seite vertretbar ist
ich denke der radikale tricks aktivist
ist einer der widerlichsten romanfiguren
geschaffen habe
wenn er hier mit unserem tisch setzen
würden wir ihn beide hassen
doch hat er ein prinzip das unverrückbar
ist man soll keine kreatur töten auch
keine rate die biologin alma
beitragssumme denkt genau wie er beide
wollen die umwelt schützen
doch sie betreibt real das heißt sie
kommen zum schluss dass gewisse tiere
wie ratten schweine und schafe sie es
überall auf der erde gibt womöglich
geopfert werden müssen damit tierarten
gerettet werden können die es nirgendwo
sonst auf der erde gibt außer auf diesen
inseln und wie sie wissen ist die
wichtigste spezies auf den inseln das
raubtier an der spitze der nahrungskette
der insel grau fuchs das ist ein
netzwerk haft kleine art etwa so groß
wie eine hauskatze zwei kilo schwer
ich hatte einen in meinen armen sie
sehen aus als hätte walt disney sie nur
für diesen kampf geschaffen ich war auf
den inseln mit der feld biologin rachel
wohlsten kraft bekannt als fox
sie fängt die tiere und schaut ob sie
gesund sind
manchen liegt sie ein senderhalsband um
damit seiner bewegungen verfolgen kann
denn sie wären fast ausgerottet worden
inzwischen haben sie sich durch die
wiederherstellung des ökosystems erholt
das war wohl das aufregendste das ich je
erlebt habe mit ihr in der totalen
wildnis diese tiere aufzuspüren
selbst das merkt man immer wenn man sie
liest sind sind mittendrin in diesem
amerikanischen leben in diesem lifestyle
auch für uns europäer merkt man das ist
typisch amerikanische gesellschaft die
sie diese schildern auch mit diesen eben
für uns manchmal ein bisschen
historischen aspekten
sie selbst sind eine art verkörperung
des american dream für uns sie kommen
aus dem nichts quasi aus dem unter nicht
seine sehr schwere jugend kindheit
gehabt sie leben heute in einer
wunderbaren wieder mit 174 fenstern von
frank lloyd wright und verbrennen und
verschleudern energie in diesem haus
nämlich an
alles andere als alles umweltschutz las
ich sie haben habe ich drei autos in
ihrem haushalt man könnte die liste
weiter ziehen aber auf der anderen seite
sind sie ein naturschutz aktivist sie
rezykliert unglaublich manisch wie ich
gelesen habe und haben in der sierra
nevada eineinhalb seine hütte vielleicht
sogar wo sie sich zurückziehen
diese diese schizophrenie ist das quasi
wie umweltschutz als lifestyle oder als
hobby
wir sind doch diesbezüglich alle ein
wenig schizophren
ich habe das bedürfnis allein in der
natur zu sein
deswegen bin ich ein umweltschützer wir
müssen zum roman ein freund der erde
zurück gehen die nicht 2010 er handelt
von einem öko aktivisten spielt im jahr
2025 und es geht um die globale
erwärmung der protagonist tidewater seit
dem leser ihnen uns allen
ich war kriminell wie ihr das heißt nur
schon in einer westlichen gesellschaft
zu leben ist ein verbrechen gegen die
natur aber wir müssen das rational sehen
wir brauchen nun mal ressourcen wenn wir
auf diesem planeten leben
ich hatte großes glück was den
amerikanischen traum anbelangt ich bin
sozial aufgestiegen
ich bin der erste aus unserer familie
der ans college gehen ein vater wuchs im
waisenhaus auf und besuchte dort die
grundschule
meine mutter war im waisenhaus bis zum
abschluss der high school
zudem lebe ich in einer demokratie kann
sagen tun und anziehen was ich will
tatsächlich hat noch nie jemand nein zu
mir gesagt das ist mein glück und es ist
wunderbar das haus in dem wir wohnen war
am zerfall und wir haben es renoviert es
war schon da wir haben es nicht neu
erbaut es ist ein 102 jahre alt
dieses holz gibt es heute nicht mehr
das ist ein verbrechen aber vor 100
jahren gab es noch rettungs und dort
steht und zu den autos kann ich nur
sagen wir müssen in den usa viel fahren
jedes meiner kinder hat ein auto aber
seit wir vor 19 jahren in dieses dorf
gezogen sind brauchen wir das auto
praktisch nie wir erleben sehr gesund
gehen zu fuß in die bars und restaurants
zur bank in den supermarkt an den strand
das macht das leben nicht nur ökologisch
sondern vorher lebte ley für alles sogar
um die schuhe zubinden brauchte ich ein
auto um ein sandwich zu kaufen muss die
35 kilometer fahren es war ein ständiger
kampf aber können sieben milliarden
menschen in einem dorf leben
ich denke nicht sie haben das kurz
gesagt diese dieser engagierte
umweltschützer sagt ich bin auch ein
verbrecher so wie du so wie du wie wir
alle
und dass wir alle quasi die ökologische
unschuld verloren haben
es ist also nicht etwas äußeres das uns
zu einem besseren handeln antreibt weil
es das gar nicht gibt dass wir wieder an
grenzen stoßen sondern muss eine innere
stimme sein die uns zu moralischen wesen
machten es gibt eine stelle in ihrem
buch weil ich ein bisschen erschüttert
war und weil man sieht dass der
schaeffler der sich so einsetzt für die
tiere selbst aber einen wunderbaren
kunstrasen legt in seiner villa und
dieser kunstrasen wird gefressen von den
waschbären und er diese waschbären dann
von seinem grundstück fernhalten will
fallen aufstellt sogar zwei schnappt ein
muttertier und ein kind und hier
schreiben sie in dieser stelle wenn als
als dave dee fallen inspizieren geht und
sieht er hat etwas gefangen
was empfindet er erstaunt ja hier sind
die mysteriösen kreaturen der nacht sie
haben form und gestalt sie sind gefangen
in seiner hand gegeben
ihre existenz ist so greifbar wie seine
eigene er ist befriedigt er hat recht
gehabt aber empfindet auch eine seltsame
macht die überlegenheit seines witzes
diese beiden haben ihn angegriffen wenn
auch unwissentlich und ihren natürlichen
instinkten gehorchend und nun hat das
sie und kann mit ihnen machen was er
will
das ist eigentlich wie aus dem tagebuch
eines kz wärters er kann machen mit
ihnen wasser will und das gibt ihm eine
eine lust und diese lust gilt es zu
unterdrücken
mein kompliment juriert schön gelesen
und gut ausgesucht ja natürlich wieder
spiele ich mit den ironien unseres
umgangs mit der natur
dave ist mit einer situation aus seinem
leben konfrontiert
es ist einfach zu sagen man müsse alle
tiere retten so lange sie eine nicht
belästigen
sobald er diesen perfekten rasen anlegen
wird dieser von den waschbären verwüstet
und er muss etwas dagegen tun
er ist nicht sehr konsequent
aber er tötet die tiere sagt er versteht
dass sie das recht haben dort zu sein
wie sie gesagt haben das ist wie in
einem konzentrationslager oder wien
einem zu votieren engen gehegen gehalten
werden
zu unserer ergötzen ich denke die leser
knüpfen viele verbindungen zu ihrem
eigenen leben
dave würde diese tiere gerne beseitigen
er geht zu einer kontrollstelle und
geben ihm eine falle um sie einzufangen
aber was soll er mit ihnen tun
er kann sie nicht in die kontrollstelle
bringen dort will man sie nicht
er kann sie auch nicht einfach im wald
frei lassen denn dort haben andere war
sperren ihr territorium und die
fremdlinge würden vermutlich eines
grausamen todes sterben
er steht also vor der großen frage was
er mit diesen tieren tun soll
soll ich ihnen sagen wie ich das mache
mein grundstück ist sehr alt eigentlich
ist es einfach ein bald ich habe dort
einen teich für die tiere ausgehoben vor
ein paar jahren ist ein riesiger
eukalyptus baum umgestürzt und ich habe
ihn liegen gelassen
generationen von waschbären leben
darunter ich war schon oft mit
journalisten das ist möglich weil die
tiere tagsüber schlafen und ich bin dort
im wissen dass sie darunter liegen und
dann in der nacht aktiv werden und alles
zerstören
ich finde das ist ihr recht es ist gut
so also sie haben ihre innere gute
stimme hat gesiegt was tatsächlich aber
interessant ist es gibt diese grenze
diese fließende grenze zwischen
umweltschutzaktivisten und öko
terroristen und ich habe mich ein
bisschen umgeschaut bei unserem
schweizer national schriftsteller max
frisch der kurz nach dem krieg in den
1940 er jahren über den terrorismus
geschrieben hat und gesagt hat dass
terrorismus sich besonders zur
vernichtung von sittlichen menschen
eignet also das sittliche menschen zu
terrorismus neigen ist das etwas was
bedeuten würde dass umweltschützer sehr
gefährdet sind öko terroristen zu werden
aus ihrem südlichen bewusstsein das
glaube ich nicht
in meinen beiden romanen
öko saboteure in diesem und ihn ein
freund der erde engagieren sich die
protagonisten mehr auf und persönliche
vorurteile oder wegen eines verlangens
dass viele haben außer ich denn ich bin
perfekt aber viele haben das verlangen
die dinge zu beherrschen und zu
kontrollieren deshalb geht es in solchen
organisationen oft nicht in erster linie
darum tierarten oder die umwelt zu
schützen
es wird zu einer art grabenkampf wäre
anrecht auf dieses land und auf alles
was darauf legt eine entspanntere
haltung hatten vielleicht die wahren
gurus der vergangenheit wie gandhi
nämlich alles zu akzeptieren wie es ist
und im einklang mit der natur zu leben
auch das habe ich ergründet in jobs city
das ist ein historischer romane in den
späten 1960 er jahren während der hippie
bewegung spielt ihre anhänger wollten
zurück zur natur
sie wollten den kapitalismus und in
vielen produkten den rücken kehren und
einfach erleben
zurück zur erde das war ihr motto das
habe ich verwertet ich versetzte die
hippie kommune der 60er jahre von
kalifornien nach alaska an die äußerste
grenze der usa nichts zu sehen ob das
möglich sein würde
das war es nicht ganz einfach wegen der
bevölkerungsdichte auch wenn damals nur
4,5 milliarden menschen auf der erde
lebten und noch nicht 7 milliarden wie
heute einer der protagonisten verdient
sich seinen lebensunterhalt als
fallensteller ein fallensteller braucht
40 quadratkilometern genug tiere für
seinen unterhalt fangen zu können wie
der löwe oder der grizzlybär es ist also
unmöglich wenn dort zwei oder drei
fallen stellen wären alle tiere
innerhalb eines jahres ausgerottet wir
stecken in unserem
unnatürlichen leben fest mit unserer
maschinen unseren fernsehkameras unsere
elektronik und übersetzungs stöpseln im
ohr social networks etwas anderes ist
nicht möglich es gibt nicht mehr genug
land nicht mehr genügend tiere
das würde heißen wir sind dermaßen
ökologisch traumatisiert dass wir wissen
dass es quasi gar kein zurück zur natur
gibt es gibt die wünsche die
selbstverständlich sind nach ein
bisschen luxus oder nach einem dass man
sich das leben manchmal ein bisschen
angenehm gestalten möchte und dass man
eben quasi immer schon schmutz an den
händen hat sie gehen ja sehr radikal sie
gehen ja nicht sehr viel weiter als als
gandhi sie sagen dass die zone um
tschernobyl quasi ein neues addon ist
weil es da keine menschen mehr gibt und
quasi eben die natur sich ganz radikal
wieder etwas zurück holt das ist dann
schon bank oder eigentlich das ist schon
oft wie sie gesagt haben sich in die
natur zurückziehen zu können wenn man
will ist ein luxus ich verbringe viel
zeit im sequoia national aber ich miete
dann jeweils ein haus mit elektrizität
ich kann auf deinem computer meine
bücher schreiben und wenn ich damit
fertig bin kann ich als privileg gewesen
mitten in der natur für mich allein zu
wohnen heute ist das ein luxus für leute
die sich das leisten können während wir
hier an diesem tisch sitzen verhungert
ein drittel der menschheit
viele müssen draußen leben aber unter
harten bedingungen
sie haben keine wahl diese thematik
erörtere ich in meinem buch amerika mit
dem originaltitel der teac retten da
geht es vordergründig um die illegale
immigration von mexiko nach los angeles
aber da die protagonisten draußen im
topanga canyon überleben müssen gibt es
auch um diese frage
es geht nicht um gut oder schlecht
während agonist dieses dilemmas partner
lebt ein bequemes leben in einer
geschlossenen wohnanlage über dem canyon
er liebt die natur er schreibt eine
kolumne über die natur
er liebt es zu wandern und übernachtet
gerne in seinem 300 dollar schlafsack im
wald draußen ist ironischerweise sind
aber unten im canyon menschen die nichts
haben und draußen leben müssen ständig
sie haben keine alternative und eine
weitere ironie in diesem roman der
immigrant candido der auch unten im tal
lebt hat hunger
also beginnt der vögel zu fangen und zu
essen leider handelt es sich um den
gefährdeten schluchten zaunkönig das
zeigt wie wir mit der natur umgehen
wir leben gerne umweltbewusst aber wenn
wir hunger haben es mir das letzte
lebewesen das sich bewegt und das gerne
jetzt hoffentlich sie haben mir ein
bisschen die das stichwort gegeben
amerika und hoffentlich geht das was sie
sagen nur für amerika amerika das immer
für uns auf der anderen seite des
atlantiks das sinnbild war für
optimismus
sie sind zwar ein sehr optimistischer
mensch in der form wie sie reden wie sie
schreiben sie spielen wie sie
performance aber sie haben einen radikal
und pessimismus wenn man den inhalt
ernst nimmt und gesehen dass dieser
pessimismus von amerika rüberschwappt
2008 als als obama an die macht kam kam
nochmals eine bewegung von hope und
change als amerika wo ist amerika heute
wahlkampf als einzelperson umarme ich
die ganze menschheit ich habe eine sehr
einfache beziehung zu menschen wenn sie
mich lieben liebe ich sie so einfach
und ich habe freude am leben und mache
gerne kunst ich habe schöne beziehungen
zu meinen freunden und
familienangehörigen
das ist wunderbar ich kann nicht klagen
aber auf philosophische ebene bin ich
zutiefst pessimistisch lese ich die
texte von 20 verschiedenen
umweltschützer könnte ich mich
erschießen
es gibt nicht die kleinste hoffnung für
unsere spezies darüber hinaus die
einzige gute neuigkeit dass in rund
dreieinhalb milliarden jahren die sonne
zu einem gelben riesen angewachsen und
alles verbrannt sein wird da fragt man
sich wozu setzen wir uns ein
ich gehe einen schritt zurück bis sich
etwa zwölf jahre alt war wurde ich
römisch katholisch erzogen das war in
new york meine mutter war nicht
fanatisch aber sie ging mit mir und
meiner schwester jeweils sonntags zur
kirche
und wie gesagt der glauben hat etwas
tröstliches ergibt deinem leben sind
gott führt und belohnt uns und das ist
der sinn des lebens
aber dann studierten wir in der schule
erdkunde und ich sagte zu meiner mutter
rational gesehen macht das keinen sinn
da meinte sie
du musst nicht mehr zur kirche ich bin
seither auch nicht mehr hingegangen oder
atheist mit 17 ging ich eines college
und begeisterte mich für die
existenzialisten die sata und gab sie
sagten mit gewisser übereinstimmung das
leben ist sinnlos wir sterben so oder so
doch heute realisieren wir nicht nur der
einzelne mensch und alles was er lebend
aufbaut und schafft stirbt sondern der
ganze planet jedes tier und alles
lebendige wie kann man angesichts dieser
tatsache optimistisch sein
ich wollte sie einfach nicht mehr zu
langen antworten erhöht wir könnten
natürlich die kameras sechs weitere
stunden laufen lassen dann kann ich
ihnen das alles hat
ich unterstütze aber ich bin seit jeher
demokrat und befürworte ihr
parteiprogramm umweltschutz gleiche
rechte für die frauen
multikulturalismus bildung natürlich die
hoffnung dir obama vermittelte war das
ende der unternehmerischen gier der
bush-jahre die uns praktisch zerstörte
und immer noch zerstört
obama tut was er kann er wird die
wiederwahl gewinnen und mehr demokraten
werden in die beiden häuser einziehen
vielleicht wird er dann endlich ein paar
gesetze verabschieden können
zum wohl aller ich will nicht negativ
über den umweltschutz reden ich bin
umweltschützer
sie haben vorher gesagt dass ich
fanatisch rezitieren bei uns wird nichts
weggeworfen jeder wissen der auf dem
teller liegen bleibt landet auf dem
kompost und wird später als
pflanzendünger verbindet wenn ich durch
das viertel gegen diese ich den müll
anderer auf das klingt mir sehr am
herzen
die sparsam mit wasser um mit allem was
die umwelt anbelangt obwohl es
langfristig gesehen vielleicht gar nicht
darauf ankommt aber ich kann nicht
anders und ich bin diesbezüglich
hoffnungsvoll
auch weil wir heute viel umweltbewusster
sind als früher doch schon eine
enttäuschung zu spüren also dass das
obama scheint grüne inhalt der ein
bisschen vergessen zu haben in all
diesen anderen kampfgebieten denen sich
befindet und ich habe eine umfrage
gelesen der new york times das 2005
haben 79 prozent der befragten
amerikaner an die erderwärmung geglaubt
und heute sind es noch also heute 2010
sind es noch 59 prozent also das heißt
dass die umweltthemen offensichtlich
versickern nicht mehr so virulent sind
und dass etwas vergessen gegangen ist
auch vergessen geht ganz bewusst
pragmatisch in einem
präsidentschaftswahlkampf der ein
wirtschafts wahlkampf sein wird sind sie
da nicht
aber ich kann mit anderen statistiken um
mich werfen
70 der us bürger haben kürzlich in einer
umfrage gesagt dass der umweltschutz das
wichtigste thema ist für sie und ihr
leben
ich denke es wird langsam bewusst wie
wichtig es für das überleben unseres pcs
ist dass wir die umwelt weniger belasten
schauen sie nur welche auswirkungen die
globale erwärmung bereits hat zum
beispiel diese jahrhundert stürme die
wir nun fast jede woche erleben das ist
ein desaster obama packt diese
umweltprobleme an und wird sie auch in
zukunft anpacken und ich hoffe dass ich
das verbessert andererseits das wissen
sie ist umweltbewusstsein ein luxus das
haben wir bereits gesagt wann immer die
wirtschaft einbricht oder der
benzinpreis um 20 cent steigt heißt es
fuhren wir in der arktis nach öl wir von
ihren arbeitsplätze geben wir die
umweltbestimmungen auf damit wir mehr
jobs haben
das ist selbstmord es ist falsch
man muss auf nachhaltige weise
arbeitsplätze schaffen
autofahren und waren transportieren aber
als ich ein junge war verschwindet mir
keinen gedanken an solche wir warfen
alles in den abfall
es gab kein recycling heute gibt es das
wir hatten keine alternative energien
wie sonnenenergie oder wasserstoff kraft
verschiedene autohersteller auch vw
stellen wasserstoff betriebene autos her
gibt es vier tankstellen an denen man
wasserstoff tanken kann
die technologie ist noch nicht so weit
das problem ist dass man den wasserstoff
von -200 5
grad celsius gefrieren muss um zu
verdichten aber wenn die ölfirmen uns
nicht im griff hätten könnten wir in
fünf jahren alle wasserstoff betriebene
autos fahren die motivation zum grüne
themen auf die agenda zu setzen können
ja quasi luxus momente sein weil man es
sich leisten kann weil es eine eine
gewisse befriedigung gibt man kann aber
auch angst also motivation nehmen und
ich glaube aber ich vermute ein bisschen
das saarland funktioniert nicht aber
ihre kalifornische existenz also sie
leben in einem staat muss permanent
irgendwie eine große katastrophe geben
könnte ein erdbeben überschwemmungen
feuersbrünste er haus sie haben zwei uhr
alte atommeiler in diesem staat also
jeden moment könnte die bombe hochgehen
klar beginnt man dann auch
umweltaktivist zu werden
wir leben in kalifornien ständig am rand
einer katastrophe wie sie gesagt haben
erdbeben und feuersbrünste die sind auch
erschreckend ihr glücklichen schweizer
ist keine angst haben vor feuersbrünsten
aber wir leben in einem konsum clean
die häuser sind an orten wo sie nicht
sein sollten wir kontrollieren die
brände und geben ihnen damit mehr
nahrung früher entstanden diese brände
natürlich und waren weniger extrem und
vor der globalen erwärmung gab es
weniger dürren und nicht so heftige wind
stürme in kalifornien kennen wir uns mit
katastrophen tatsächlich aus das sehen
sie in meinen geschichten und romanen
ich befasse mich oft mit diesem
apokalyptischen themen kalifornien ist
aber auch bei weitem der us-staat mit
dem stärksten umweltbewusstsein
es kann funktionieren
es funktioniert wenn wir nur die
bevölkerung reduzieren können
wie der aktivist ihr wörter in meinem
roman sagt sind wir alle kriminelle auch
ich habe mich fortgepflanzt ich habe
drei kinder eines mehr als so erhalte
bevölkerung nötig werde
das ist schrecklich andererseits bin ich
sehr glücklich und ich bin ein tier als
ich faul zum ersten mal studentin sarah
wie sie die treppe in der bibliothek
hochgehenden engen jeans und schuhe mit
hohen absätzen vergaß sich die umwelt
von und geist die umwelt moment jetzt
vergessen oder die seite schieben und
etwas über die kreativität sprechen
sie sind professor für kreatives
schreiben seit über 30 jahren ist
kreativität lernbar ich beantworte diese
frage in europa seit 25 jahren
nein man kann nicht lernen ein großer
künstler zu sein wenn man nicht ein
großes talent hat aber sie wären
überrascht wenn sie wüssten wie viele
menschen talentiert sind viele wurden
nie entdeckt viele leben ihr talent
nicht aus
sei es im bereich der poesie literatur
musik skulptur oder malerei natürlich
kann man jemanden nur künstlerisch
fördern wenn er ein großes talent hat
man kann ihn coachen und das tue ich
man lernt schneller zu sein indem man
andere schriftsteller liest und
absorbiert wie sie schreiben in dieser
hinsicht kann ich sehr unterstützen und
ich kann ihnen helfen professioneller zu
werden kann ihre texte redigieren
früher hatten die verlags lektoren die
funktion die ich heute übernehmen
das heißt sie nahmen einen jungen
unerfahrenen schriftsteller und helfen
ihn an seinem manuskript zu arbeiten und
daraus etwas gutes oder sogar großes
zimmer das tun lektoren heute nicht mehr
sie bekommen so hoch stehende
manuskripte dass sie einfach auswählen
können
womöglich arbeiten sie mit den autoren
aber in kleinerem ausmaß als noch vor 30
oder 40 jahren das kreative schreiben
dass schriftsteller wie ich anbieten hat
gewissermaßen diese funktion übernommen
überdies gab es in den universitäten
immer die fachbereiche musik und
bildende kunst es ist nur richtig dass
auch die dritte kunst die literatur
studienrichtung angeboten wird das ist
sehr einfach
ich biete den studenten ein forum in dem
sie ihre arbeit vorstellen können
ich habe gerade meine letzte klasse
abgeschlossen
am tag vor meiner abreise nach europa
ich bin nun ganz oben in der
nahrungskette
ich habe die studenten aufgrund ihrer
manuskripte ausgesucht sie sind sehr gut
schon sehr fortgeschritten und
unglaublich engagiert das semester hat
15 wochen jeder der 15 studenten hat
zweimal die chance uns eines seiner
werke vorzustellen
vorher lesen wir es machen uns notizen
dann sitzen wir zusammen und diskutieren
darüber der autor sagt nichts er hört
uns nur zu unsere aus meldungen gegen
ihm eine vorstellung wie die leserschaft
das buch aufnehmen könnte vielleicht
irgend wir uns vielleicht sind wir fans
der autor kann sagen ihr könnt mich mal
mir ist euer urteil egal das habe ich zu
sagen
oder er findet ich habe nicht realisiert
dass das ende so verwirrend ist
vielleicht schreibe ich das neu so weit
geht dass in anderen wochen und
fiktionen lesen wir kurzgeschichten von
professionellen schriftstellern und zwar
alle möglichen show und dann diskutieren
wir darüber
manchmal analysieren wir also
schriftsteller er nehmen ihre
geschichten auseinander und schauen wie
sie wirkung erzielen aber mehr nicht
ich kann den studenten nichts beibringen
auch die mitstudenten nicht nennt kann
dir sagen was du mit deiner kunst
anfangen sollst
aber vielleicht hast du neue einsichten
wenn du da aufhörst was andere sagen
wenn sie sich selbst jetzt nochmals
nehme als beispiel
sie haben so viele romane geschrieben
grandiose romane mit extremen erfolg ich
glaube das letzte buch 4 millionen
auflage das sind das ist ja nicht mehr
normal
werden sie denn selbst immer besser oder
gibt es auch so ausrutscher dies nicht
so ihr lob freut mich vielen dank ich
gebe mir große mühe das ist mein leben
ich arbeite sieben tage die woche ich
liebe das schreiben
ich wüsste nicht wie ich mich sonst mit
der welt auseinandersetzen könnte ich
schaue immer was als nächstes kommt ich
blicke nie zurück im herbst kommt in
großbritannien und in den usa mein
neuestes buch san miguel heraus es
spielt auf der äußersten der kanalinsel
ist aber keine fortsetzung dieses romans
es ist eine historische geschichte die
ich bei den recherchen zu diesem buch
entdeckt habe über nächsten herbst
kommen die tc boll stories to aus der
zweite band bei einer gesammelten werke
und ich arbeite an einer der
kurzgeschichten ich schaue immer for use
das schöne an meinem künstlerdasein ist
ich wache auf und gehe etwas nach das
nichts demoliert eine begebenheit die
sind wir heute erzählen oder die ich in
der zeitung lese etwas aus der
vergangenheit oder ein thema das sich
beschäftigt zum beispiel die umwelt im
roman wenn das schlachten vorbei ist all
das kann mich dazu anregen eine
geschichte zu schreiben
ich schaue nie zurück zu den gesammelten
geschichten habe ich eine einführung
geschrieben und darin allen
interessierten meine technik und meine
leidenschaft erklärt
und was sich in der welt zu tun aber an
den kurzgeschichten habe ich nichts
geändert
sie sind inzwischen teil der geschichte
ist ich will sie nicht neu schreiben ich
will vorwärts gehen und etwas anderes
finden sie haben gesagt das eigentlich
ihre rolle quasi die eines editors ist
eines verlegers und diese rolle wird vom
markt oder von den verlagen nicht mehr
übernommen
arbeiten sie denn mit einem mit einem
editor zusammen dass ihnen dieses
feedback gibt ich bin ein
detailversessener perfektionist das
manuskript das sich auf dem computer
scheibe entspricht praktisch dem
fertigen buch sehr selten wird noch
etwas daran geändert
das heißt nicht dass ich nicht auf
meinem verleger hören mit dem ich eng
befreundet bin ich bin einfach ein auto
mit dem man nicht viel arbeiten muss
wir sind alle verschieden gewisse
autoren wollen stärker mit ihrem
verleger zusammenarbeiten
ich will und brauche das nicht manchmal
jedoch gibt mir mein verleger paul
slovak gute anregungen in ein freund der
erde zum beispiel gibt es eine szene in
der die beiden aktivisten ein mann und
eine frau für die medienleute einen
werbegag machen
sie gehen mit ihnen in eine gegend die
ähnlich ist wie der sequoia nationalpark
wo ich lebe
es ist sommer und sie wollen
demonstrieren dass männer und frauen im
naturzustand leben können ohne all die
annehmlichkeiten der zivilisation
sie ziehen sich vor der kamera ausgeben
ihre warme unterwäsche den journalisten
und leben einen monat lang im wald ein
reporter begleitet sie um zu
kontrollieren ob sie nicht schummeln
voll sagte zu mir
diese szene ist sehr unterhaltsam ich
glaube du solltest sie ausdehnen und er
hat er nicht das habe ich gemacht sie
ist um ein drittel länger als in meiner
ersten fassung
mir ist also seine meinung sehr wichtig
und manchmal regen mich seiner
rückmeldungen an ein manuskript nochmals
zu überdenken
doch grundsätzlich wie führe ich meine
bücher druckfertig ab sicher was die
struktur betrifft meinen studenten gebe
ich nur anregungen außer es geht um die
grammatik oder die formulierung auf
solche dinge achte ich beim regieren
aber sie können meine korrekturen
zurückweisen
am ersten tag umarme ich sie und sage
ich liebe dich ich bin euer anwalt und
werde sehr roman sein
alles was ich von ihnen verlange ist
absolute perfektion
diese perfektion die beschreiben sie ja
selbst als sucht auch und ihre ihrer
jugend war ja nicht ganz zucht frei wenn
man das so sagen kann sie sind als einer
seiner familie besucht alkoholsucht ein
thema war über beide eltern sind daran
gestorben alkohol direkt oder indirekt
sie haben selbst quasi den shift
geschafft von vom lka holik zum
workaholic kann können sie ihren
studenten eben diese diese absolute
devotion gegenüber der arbeit in sucht
begriffen vertreten
ja natürlich sie sind vom selben virus
erfasst wie ich deshalb arbeite ich
gerne mit ihnen und bin ihr lehrer und
anwalt die besten studenten sind viel
weiter als ich in ihrem alter war
sie sind ihrer kunst voll und ganz
ergeben und sie sind großartig
sie können sich nicht vorstellen wie gut
sie sind und was aus ihnen wird mir
gefällt ihr vergleich von drogensucht
und arbeit vielleicht wissen sie dass
ich darüber einen essay geschrieben habe
hermann k on your back heißt dass man
drogensüchtig ist und die drogensucht
habe ich mit der arbeit sucht ersetzt
vergleiche ich das gefühl dass einem
heroin vermittelt mit dem gefühl das man
hat wenn man eine geschichte erfindet es
ist ein hoch wenn ich eine geschichte zu
schreiben beginne weiß ich nicht was
dabei herauskommt ich ergreife eine
chance ich gehe etwas nach und in einem
tage oder wochen langen prozess fügt
sich alles zusammen und ich beginne zu
sehen was daraus wird
wenn ich fertig bin ist das
überwältigend
im freudenrausch ähnlich dem heroin
frisch wie bei einer droge lässt die
wirkung nach und du willst das wieder
und wieder
das wird seine art von obsession aber
man wird dafür auch belohnt
mit diesem thema sucht um also auch mit
ihren kindern sind drei kinder ist sucht
1 1 angst thema für sie ich versuche ein
normales leben zu führen und ein netter
kerl zu sein der am fernsehshows
auftritt und die zuschauer auf der
ganzen welt unterhält
ich will gut sein zu meiner frau den
kindern und allen nachbarn gewisser
hinsicht bin ich wohl ein seltsamer
schriftsteller die meisten autoren sind
introvertiert sie wollen mit niemandem
zu tun haben
sie haben ihr persönliches inneres chaos
und drücken das für uns aus sicher habe
ich diese seite auch wenn ich meine
tournee beendet habe ziehe ich mich in
die einsamkeit zurück und will niemanden
sehen ich denke aber dass man die beiden
seiten im gleichgewicht halten kann
ich habe einmal den schriftsteller john
gardiner getroffen
er sagte zu mir dass er jeden tag von 7
uhr bis 11 uhr nachts an seinen romanen
arbeite sagte das ist das schrecklichste
das ich je gehört habe wie im gefängnis
ich versuche zu arbeiten so lange es
fließt
vielleicht sind das drei oder vier
stunden und wenn ich etwas abschließe
fünf oder sechs stunden
aber ich strebe eine ausgewogenheit dann
mache ich etwas körperliches gehe nach
draußen fälle einen toten baum im garten
panzer etwas andere durch den wald so
viel mehr genehmige mir einen drink in
einer bar oder
düstere stimmungen oder die gegend ist
und dass ein normales leben in the place
in your life
trotzdem natürlich also ist ihre figur
diese kunstfigur von der wir gesprochen
haben
der golden age der mit punk pop operiert
der coolness verkörpert wird ja auch
eben irgendwann mal alt und dieses
dieses rock'n roll problem wie wird man
alt als rockstar gewissermaßen ist etwas
das ist nicht nur ein problem für mich
ich habe schlechte neuigkeiten für sie
juri sie attraktiver junger mann werden
mit viel glück auch einmal als sein mit
meinem arzt wirklich gerne darüber
er ist älter als ich ich sage zu ihm uns
als sein ist neu für mich sie können mir
da helfen
ich weiß nicht die öffentlichkeit hat
ein bild von mir aber ich bin einfach
mein eigener herr und meister ich tue
was immer ich werde ich kleide mich
niemand hat mir gesagt ich müsse mich
irgendeiner norm anpassen ich sehe noch
gleich aus wie vor 40 jahren und tue die
gleichen dinge
es kümmert mich nicht groß so weit so
gut so lange ich noch atmen gehen und
schreiben kann geht es mir gut ich bin
ja wirklich ein extrem älterer herren
ich werde an man im nächsten geburtstag
87 jahre alt das heißt aber nicht dass
ich dann anzüge tragen und am stock
gehen muss mit einem alten mann zusammen
frau beuel ist wie sie sich vorstellen
können eine der tolerantesten frauen die
je gelebt haben grundsätzlich behandelt
sie nicht gleich wie unsere 3
manchmal ist unser sohn meiler zu hause
er ist gitarrist und schreibt songs wenn
ich in sein zimmer schaue sitzt da sein
motor und strickt während er ihr seinen
song for spielt weil er von ihr gelobt
werden und eine stunde später sind sie
bei millionen strikt und ich lese hier
vor was ich gerade geschrieben habe ganz
zum schluss möchte ich sie fragen sie
haben einmal in einem interview
ihre utopische gesellschaft vorstellung
kurz skizziert heißt nicht ob sie sich
erinnern können mit geschlossenen augen
und sie haben gesagt sie streben eine
diktatur des buches an und würden wenn
sie diese dikatur verwirklicht hätten
alle tv fernsehfrequenzen auf der welt
für immer neutralisieren kein fernsehen
mehr wirklich dass ich ihnen jetzt sagen
tut mir leid und das ist doch grotesk
denn schon so oft war ich im fernsehen
und kritisierte die dominanz dieses
mediums damit will ich sagen ich komme
aus einer arbeiterfamilie
als ich klein war hatten wir keine
bücher wenn ihr aus der schule oder von
der arbeit nach hause kamen wurde der
fernseher eingeschaltet
und wenn wir zu bett gingen wurde er
ausgeschaltet und für viele menschen auf
der welt ist das die einzige
unterhaltung und natürlich anders als
diese brillante sendung im bewährten
zuschauer mit wunderbaren ideen für die
meisten ist das fernsehen die einzige
unterhaltung sie es beruhigend und das
ist in ordnung ich kritisiere dass es
für die meisten keine alternative gibt
ich schaue mir gerne bbc filme auf pbs
an
ich schaue gerne alte schwarzweiß sehe
ich mir eine sportübertragung an aber
nur ausgewählte sendungen und das ist
toll aber ich habe andere ressourcen und
befasse mich auch mit anderen dingen
doch zurück zur neutralisierung der
fernseh frequenzen machen sie sich da
keine sorgen ich habe mich noch nicht
mehr damit befasst denn ich verschwende
allem eine zeitnahme bücher und
geschichten zu schreiben
bitteschön
[Musik]